Cette vidéo est destinée aux étudiants de
Prépa ECG (anciennement Prépa HEC). En effet,
les épreuves de dissertation de
culture générale des concours des
grandes écoles de commerce qui
auront lieu l’année prochaine,
en 2024 — ces épreuves de dissertation
porteront sur le thème de la violence.
Deux petites précisions avant de vous
lire ma dissertation modèle.
Tout d’abord, vous pouvez télécharger le texte
de cette dissertation. Pour l’obtenir, c​​liquez
sur le lien qui apparaît en haut à droite de la
vidéo ; ou bien cliquez sur celui qui est dans
la description ; ou bien encore tapez directement
1000idcg.com/violence dans la barre de recherche.
Ensuite, il vous suffira de vous inscrire
avec votre adresse e-mail ; de confirmer
votre inscription en ouvrant le premier e-mail
que vous recevrez ; et vous recevrez alors
ma dissertation dans l’e-mail suivant.
S’il y a un souci, vous pouvez m’écrire
à romain@1000idcg.com.
Seconde précision préliminaire,
inspirée par le fait que pas mal d’élèves m’ont
déjà posé la même question : oui, je vais bien
proposer mes 50 paragraphes « tout cuits » sur
le thème de la violence. Comme chaque année,
il n’y a que 100 places, c’est pourquoi
certains élèves ont déjà réservé la leur.
Si ça vous intéresse, cliquez sur le
lien qui apparaît en haut à droite de
la vidéo ; ou bien cliquez sur celui qui est dans
la description ; ou bien encore tapez directement
1000idcg.com/50ptc dans la barre de recherche.
Bien sûr, vous pouvez me poser vos questions par
e-mail, en écrivant à romain@1000idcg.com.
Voilà voilà, c’est bon pour les précisions
préliminaires. Je vais maintenant vous
lire ma dissertation modèle sur le
sujet « la violence ».
________________
La sexologue américaine Susan Block réhabilite le
cri pacifiste des années 1960 « Faites l’amour,
pas la guerre ». Dans La voie du bonobo
: l'évolution de la paix par le plaisir,
elle exhorte les hommes du XXIe siècle
à s’inspirer de leur plus proche cousin
génétique. Ils devraient résoudre leurs
conflits et renforcer les liens sociaux
en multipliant les rapports sexuels. Ce
plaidoyer en apparence utopique invite
à questionner la nature de la violence humaine.
Le Dictionnaire de l’Académie française distingue
deux sens essentiels du nom commun « violence
». C’est tout d’abord la force elle-même,
plus précisément le fait d'agir sur quelqu'un ou
de le faire agir contre sa volonté en employant
la force ou l'intimidation (la violence parentale
qui se manifeste dans la fessée, par exemple). Le
second sens essentiel du mot « violence » est le
fait que la force ne soit pas contenue, et qu’elle
risque par là d’engendrer un dommage (la violence
d’un coup de pied, par exemple). Enfin, le mot
désigne le plus souvent la violence physique,
mais elle peut également être psychologique.
Les hommes semblent éprouver une aversion
naturelle pour la violence. Ils la condamnent
spontanément. Si la vie sociale moderne ne
ressemble pas encore à la foire sexuelle
des bonobos, les mentalités occidentales obéissent
cependant à un puissant idéal de non-violence. Cet
idéal transparaît aussi bien dans la perception
des enjeux militaires par l’opinion publique,
dans la vie économique, dans l’éducation, dans
le traitement des animaux, que dans de banals
conflits entre particuliers. Les esprits modernes
tolèrent de moins en moins la violence. Ils
stigmatisent par exemple les « micro-agressions ».
Leur sensibilité s’exacerbe au point d’assimiler
tout rapport d’autorité à une forme de violence.
Comment expliquer cette répugnance ? Peut-être
s’agit-il d’un penchant inné de l’esprit
humain. Faut-il en déduire que l’agression
est une anomalie, une exception pathologique
dans la vie sociale ? Cette hypothèse paraît peu
crédible étant donné l’abondance et la diversité
des phénomènes de violence dans l’histoire.
Serait-ce alors, au contraire, une dimension
incontournable du destin de l’humanité ?
La violence humaine est-elle une aberration ?
Si les hommes répugnent naturellement à la
violence, elle paraît cependant ancrée dans
le registre ordinaire de leur comportement,
mais la propension à la violence de l’humanité
semble inexorablement s'étioler.
L’aversion spontanée pour la violence serait
naturelle parce que l’agression constituerait
une déviation du comportement humain.
En premier lieu, la violence est contraire
au besoin de sécurité. Cette idée vaut pour tous
les animaux, pas seulement pour l’homme. En effet,
un organisme vivant diffère d’un rocher ou
d’une rivière en ce qu’il a tendance à rendre
coup pour coup. Toute agression implique
donc un risque de réplique immédiate — sans
parler des représailles futures. En suivant ce
raisonnement, l’impératif de survie doit empêcher
les comportements violents. C’est pour cette
raison que Rousseau imagine un état de nature
pacifique. Il part de l’idée que la conservation
de la vie est le premier et le plus important des
soins pour tout animal, y compris l’être humain.
Ce qu’il appelle l’« amour de soi », l’instinct
de conservation qui habite tout être vivant,
inspire une répugnance innée à l’égard de la
violence. Rousseau en déduit que l’homme naturel
cherche uniquement à se protéger : « Les hommes
[étaient] plutôt farouches que méchants, et plus
attentifs à se garantir du mal qu’ils pouvaient
recevoir que tentés d’en faire à autrui »
(Discours sur l’origine de l’inégalité). La
logique de la survie disqualifie donc la violence
comme une déviation du comportement humain.
Mais l’amour de soi n’est pas le seul frein à
l’agression. Non seulement l’homme prend un risque
en attaquant un autre animal, mais il est lié à
ses semblables par un sentiment spécial. Il est
capable de se mettre à leur place par la pensée,
de ressentir leurs émotions — en particulier de
souffrir lorsqu’il les voit souffrir — et
d’harmoniser ses intérêts avec les leurs.
La tradition philosophique occidentale a donné
divers noms à ce penchant (c’est par exemple
la « sympathie » dans la théorie morale d’Adam
Smith). Les psychologues scientifiques parlent,
eux, d’« empathie ». Le destin de Jean
Valjean dans Les Misérables en est une
bonne illustration. Ce personnage, un forçat
échappé du bagne, était pourtant prédisposé
à la psychopathie par son passé violent. Mais
la générosité de l’évêque Myriel à son égard le
rend altruiste. Jean Valjean promet à Fantine, une
pauvre femme mourante, de prendre soin de Cosette,
sa fille exploitée par un couple d’aubergistes,
les Thénardier. Il sauvera même l’inspecteur qui
l’avait arrêté, Javert, lors d’une insurrection
parisienne. Cet exemple montre que l’empathie
est une force qui s’oppose à la violence.
Enfin, il semble que l’intérêt collectif se
superpose aux tendances individuelles. La violence
pose en effet un problème essentiel à toute
communauté humaine : elle trouble la coopération.
Si les membres ne se font plus confiance,
s’ils se craignent les uns les autres, alors ils
ne peuvent plus s’entendre en vue d’un but commun.
Ils ne peuvent plus produire des richesses,
créer de l’art, enrichir leur vie sociale,
ni améliorer leur organisation pour la rendre plus
juste. Cette idée suggère que la pacification des
rapports humains est la condition du bonheur de la
collectivité. Voltaire emploie cet argument dans
son Traité sur la tolérance. Il pointe surtout
du doigt le fanatisme chrétien, qui commet la
violence au nom d’un prophète qui prônait la
non-violence. Or, la diversité des cultes favorise
aussi bien la prospérité de la population que
celle de l’État. « Le commerce et l’agriculture y
ont gagné, écrit Voltaire à propos de la tolérance
religieuse, et le corps politique n’en a jamais
souffert ». Ainsi, la tolérance est avantageuse
parce que la violence entrave la prospérité.
Les hommes répugnent donc naturellement à
l’agression aussi bien par intérêt commun que
par des tendances individuelles. Cette conclusion
doit néanmoins être mise à l’épreuve des faits.
Les phénomènes de violence ne sont ni rares
ni limités dans l’histoire de l’humanité.
Petite interruption parce que
je me dis que si tu m’écoutes,
c’est pas pour devenir philosophe professionnel.
Non, tu m’écoutes parce que tu veux te préparer
de la manière la plus efficace qui soit pour
réussir tes dissertations de culture générale.
Et du coup je me dis que tu as probablement
compris qu’un cours de 300 pages n’est pas la
solution. Au contraire, c’est plutôt le problème.
Si tu as conscience de ce problème,
alors j’ai une solution pour toi.
Chaque année, je prépare 50 paragraphes modèles
sur le thème que j’ai baptisés — avec un brin
de provocation — 50 paragraphes « tout cuits ».
L’idée est simple : tu n’as plus besoin
de rédiger toi-même le développement de
tes dissertations puisque tu connais déjà
une cinquantaine de paragraphes prérédigés
qui permettent de défendre tous les arguments
envisageables sur tous les sujets envisageables
avec les références idéales. Et si je sais que ça
marche pour tous les sujets, c’est parce que je
traite moi-même tous les sujets possibles dans
un premier temps (c’est comme ça que je trouve
les arguments des paragraphes). D’ailleurs, depuis
plusieurs années, je fournis avec les paragraphes
une cinquantaine de plans détaillés modèles.
Les avantages de cette solution, c’est que tu
n’as plus besoin de cours, que tu n’as plus
besoin de chercher un plan ni des arguments,
et que tu seras surnoté(e) parce que les
paragraphes sont bien mieux rédigés que si tu
les rédigeais toi-même (ce qui fait que ta copie
sort du lot). Les élèves me disent aussi qu’ils
sont beaucoup moins stressés pendant l’épreuve,
qu’ils se sentent confiants et à l’aise.
Bref, mes 50 paragraphes « tout cuits » te feront
gagner facilement et rapidement des points... tout
en gagnant beaucoup de temps. Ce qui te permet
de gagner des points dans les autres matières,
tout particulièrement en maths.
Si tu veux en savoir plus, clique
sur le lien qui apparaît en haut à droite de la
vidéo ; ou bien clique sur celui qui est dans
la description ; ou bien encore tape directement
1000idcg.com/50ptc dans la barre de recherche.
Et puis si tu as des questions,
écris-moi à romain@1000idcg.com.
La réalité de la violence crédibilise l’idée
selon laquelle l’agression serait ancrée dans
le registre ordinaire du comportement humain.
Cette idée s’éclaire tout d’abord, comme celle
de la répugnance naturelle à la violence, à
la lumière du primat de la survie. Survivre
demande certes de vivre en sécurité. Mais
les enjeux concrets de la coexistence des
êtres vivants sont plus complexes. Par exemple,
un organisme a intérêt à risquer d’en agresser
un autre pour ne pas mourir de faim, ou encore
pour éviter une atteinte ultérieure plus grave
à son intégrité physique. Telle est, d’après
la théorie des jeux, la logique naturelle des
représailles : elles protègent leurs auteurs
contre de futures agressions. Hobbes conçoit
un état de nature hostile à partir de cette même
logique. L’homme de la préhistoire n’ignore pas
le danger inhérent à toute initiative violente
— seulement, il est persuadé que les autres vont
l’agresser. Il a donc intérêt à prendre lui-même
l’initiative d’attaquer, c’est-à-dire qu’il
attaque par anticipation. Les hommes de l’état
de nature, conclut Hobbes, « sont dans cette
condition qui se nomme guerre, et cette guerre est
guerre de chacun contre chacun » (Léviathan). Son
argumentation montre ainsi que la survie
peut également favoriser l’agression.
Mais là encore, les passions humaines se mêlent
à l’impératif de survie. De la même manière
qu’il existe un penchant altruiste, il existe
également un penchant à vouloir l’infortune
d’autrui. Il se manifeste notamment dans la
quête de l’honneur (ou du statut social dans la
terminologie moderne). L’homme veut être reconnu
et respecté par ses semblables. Ce désir est si
fort qu’il est prêt à recourir à l’agression pour
l’accomplir. L’intrigue du Cid de Corneille est un
exemple classique du rôle de l’honneur dans
la violence humaine. Au début de la pièce,
le père de Chimène, Don Gomès, insulte
le père de Don Rodrigue, Don Diègue,
en lui donnant une gifle. Ce faisant, il bafoue
l’honneur de la famille de Don Rodrigue. Celui-ci
est alors contraint de venger l'honneur
de son père en défiant en duel Don Gomes,
le père de la femme qu’il aime. Il le tue
bien que cela puisse lui coûter son amour
pour Chimène. « Que de maux et de pleurs
nous coûteront nos pères ! », s’écrie-t-il,
bien conscient de la logique pernicieuse de
l’honneur qui enchérit sur l’impératif de survie.
Rendue crédible par la psychologie individuelle,
l’hypothèse d’un penchant humain naturel à
l’agression devient encore plus convaincante en
considérant les comportements collectifs. Malgré
ses conséquences désastreuses, la guerre n’est
pas un phénomène exceptionnel — au contraire,
elle est un fond omniprésent dans l’histoire des
civilisations. Des groupes humains organisés ne
cessent de prendre les armes les uns contre les
autres. L’Odyssée d’Homère offre par exemple un
aperçu du rapport des hommes de la Grèce antique
à la guerre. Ils voient les conflits militaires
comme un aspect inexorable de l’existence.
Leur fatalisme transparaît dans le fait qu’ils
imputent la guerre à la colère des dieux plutôt
que de l’envisager comme un problème humain
soluble. « Nous sommes des hommes, se lamente
Ulysse, à qui Zeus, je le vois, inflige le destin
de dévider le fil des guerres douloureuses. » Les
Grecs de l’Antiquité vivent ainsi dans l’hypothèse
d’une mort soudaine et violente. Les femmes
guettent avec inquiétude à l’horizon des voiles
annonciatrices d’un tournant tragique dans leur
vie. L’agression militaire passe à cette époque
pour un événement naturel dans la vie collective.
La guerre, la logique de l’honneur et la prédation
accréditent donc l’idée que l’agression
serait inscrite dans le registre ordinaire
du comportement humain. Cette conclusion
nous incline au pessimisme. Toutefois,
elle ne signifie pas que les hommes seront à
jamais prisonniers de leur propre violence.
En observant l’histoire sur le temps
long, il apparaît en réalité que la
propension à la violence de l’humanité
semble inexorablement s'étioler.
La raison la plus évidente de cette évolution
serait l’émergence d’États stables. En effet,
ce développement politique de l’humanité
transforme les rapports entre individus
et entre groupes. Ils sont désormais contraints
de résoudre leurs conflits par l’intermédiaire
d’institutions et de processus légaux plutôt que
par la violence. L’évolution a déjà commencé en
Europe lorsque Hobbes prône l’instauration d’un
État assez fort pour interdire les violences
privées. Elle se poursuit aux XVIIIe et XIXe
siècles jusqu’à ce que l’État conquière, selon
la fameuse définition de Max Weber, le « monopole
de la violence légitime » (Le savant et le
politique). Le sociologue part du constat que le
recours à la violence physique est un moyen normal
d’exercice du pouvoir dans tous les groupements
politiques. Or, ce moyen était fragmenté en
Occident jusqu’à la fin du Moyen Âge. L’État
moderne est donc l’aboutissement d’un processus
d’expropriation politique. L’origine du processus
est la volonté du prince d’exproprier les
puissances « privées » indépendantes qui, à côté
de lui, détenaient un pouvoir administratif. Au
bout du processus, seuls les agents de l’autorité
publique sont autorisés à manier la force.
Cette explication convaincante est cependant
partielle. En effet, non seulement les citoyens
des États occidentaux contemporains n’ont pas le
droit d’être violents, mais — dans leur immense
majorité — ils n’en ont pas du tout envie. Ils
condamnent l’agression et la stigmatisent jusque
dans le langage. Comment élucider l’allergie à la
violence de l’homme moderne ? Norbert Elias met en
lumière une profonde évolution des mentalités.
De nouvelles normes sociales se sont propagées
dans les sociétés européennes depuis la fin du
Moyen Âge, au point de transformer la psychologie
individuelle en l’espace de quelques siècles. Les
Européens ont appris à inhiber leurs pulsions,
à anticiper les conséquences à long terme
et à considérer les pensées et sentiments
d'autrui. La culture de l'honneur légitimant
la vengeance a été remplacée par une culture
de la dignité qui valorise la maîtrise de
soi. « On faisait un art de se moucher,
décrit Elias. Le point de perfection consistait
à ne faire ni trop de bruit ni trop peu » (La
civilisation des mœurs). Le nouvel idéal de
la civilité s’est propagé des aristocrates
et chevaliers aux autres classes,
jusqu’à intégrer finalement la
culture dans son ensemble. Dès lors, la
morale sociale dévalorise la violence.
La stigmatisation de la violence semble toutefois
épargner la guerre. L’illusion révélée par la
formule apocryphe de Staline selon laquelle « la
mort d’un homme est une tragédie ; la mort d’un
million d’hommes est une statistique » — cette
illusion résisterait au processus de civilisation
reconstitué par Elias. Il paraît difficile, voire
indécent de défendre l’idée d’un déclin de la
violence humaine après les horreurs commises au
XXe siècle, en particulier celles des deux guerres
mondiales. Mais l’idée n’est pas déraisonnable une
fois qu’on l’examine. D’un point de vue comptable,
la violence guerrière du siècle dernier est
moindre rapportée à la population totale et
en prenant en compte les effets indirects des
guerres du passé (tels que les famines et les
maladies). De surcroît, elle a traumatisé
la conscience collective. La diplomatie
s’est alors déployée dans la direction imaginée
par Kant dans De la paix perpétuelle. Un ordre
politique international se construit, en vertu
duquel les États s’agressent plus difficilement
que par le passé. L’idée, certes contestable,
d’une communauté internationale protectrice de
la paix pénètre l’opinion publique. Enfin,
comme l’escomptait Kant, les citoyens des
démocraties contemporaines sont réticents à
supporter les coûts des conflits armés.
La violence suscite un rejet spontané qui
demande à être élucidé. L’idée que l’agression
est une déviation du comportement humain paraît
satisfaisante pour expliquer la stigmatisation
de la violence par la morale sociale. En effet,
le besoin de sécurité, la force de l’empathie et
l’intérêt collectif à la paix donnent à penser
que la violence humaine est une aberration. Mais
cette idée se révèle fragile. L’abondance et la
diversité des phénomènes de violence inspirent au
contraire l’hypothèse que l’agression appartient
au registre ordinaire du comportement humain. Les
preuves accréditant cette hypothèse ne sont pas
minces : la pression de la survie, la logique
pernicieuse de l’honneur, et l’omniprésence des
guerres dans l’histoire de l’humanité. La réalité
de la violence ne justifie pas pour autant
un retour au fatalisme des Grecs. Les hommes
sont à la vérité de moins en moins violents. Les
États leur imposent de résoudre leurs conflits
par des processus légaux, et la morale sociale
ostracise les individus qui échouent à contrôler
leur agressivité. Enfin, cette pacification
des rapports individuels semble se reproduire
à l’échelle des nations. Peut-être suffira-t-il
de cultiver le droit plutôt que la virtuosité
sexuelle des bonobos.
________________
Si tu aimes l’esprit de cette vidéo, à
savoir travailler avec des idées claires
pour être le plus efficace possible, alors tu
devrais t’inscrire à mes 50 paragraphes « tout
cuits » sur le thème de la violence.
Ce sont 50 paragraphes prêts à l'emploi
qui couvrent tous les arguments possibles sur le
thème de la violence, avec dans chaque paragraphe
la référence idéale (la plupart du temps
classique, mais aussi parfois originale)
pour justifier l’argument. Ils sont accompagnés
d’une cinquantaine de plans détaillés modèles qui
permettent de traiter tous les sujets possibles.
Du coup, tu réussiras facilement tes dissertations
sans apprendre ton cours, sans chercher un plan ni
des arguments, et sans rédiger le développement.
Tu seras scandaleusement surnoté(e) grâce au
style simple, fluide, efficace et facile à
imiter avec lequel je rédige les paragraphes.
Enfin, mes 50 paragraphes « tout cuits », c’est
aussi la solution la plus rapide pour
préparer un DS. Grâce à la playlist audio,
tes révisions se résumeront à écouter les
paragraphes pendant 1 heure dans toutes
les circonstances imaginables : en marchant,
en courant, dans les transports, à la salle
de sport, ou encore… au fond de la classe !
Par exemple, Léa m’a raconté qu’elle écoutait
les paragraphes en faisant du vélo d’appartement,
et qu’étant donné qu’elle en faisait chaque jour,
elle savait tout ce qu’elle avait besoin de savoir
pour ses dissertations de culture générale sans
avoir passé une seule minute dans son cours.
Comme ça fait 7 ans que je propose mes
paragraphes « tout cuits », j’ai
reçu beaucoup d’autres témoignages.
Regarde celui-ci qui date de 2017 : « L’année
dernière, je plafonnais à 8 en dissertation,
j’étais dans les tous derniers.
Aujourd’hui, le prof rend les copies,
je majore la classe avec 17. »
Effectivement, l’avantage de mes
paragraphes « tout cuits », c’est
que tu gagnes des points rapidement,
pas dans 6 mois mais dès le prochain DS.
Le prochain témoignage est celui d’Alex.
Il m’a écrit sur Messenger : « Je me suis
rappelé que je ne t’avais jamais remercié pour
ta méthode (qui m’a, on peut le dire, sauvé). »
Alex dit que mes paragraphes « tout cuits » l’ont
sauvé parce que la culture générale n’était
pas sa matière forte et qu’en plus il ne l’a
quasiment pas travaillée. Avec son niveau, il
pensait se ramasser aux concours — mais il a
fini avec 13 à HEC et 15 à l’ESSEC (la
prestigieuse école qu’il a intégrée).
Le dernier témoignage que je veux te montrer
est un peu drôle. Roland m’écrit : « Même
si j’ai eu 15/20, je pense que c’est plutôt
grâce à tes paragraphes tout cuits très bien
rédigés plutôt que grâce à ma dissertation. »
Roland pense qu’il a été surnoté parce que le
style de mes paragraphes « tout cuits
» a fait sortir sa copie du lot.
Je sais, j’ai promis que c’était le dernier
témoignage — mais je veux quand même t’en
montrer un tout dernier, parce que c’est celui
d’un prof. J’ai flouté beaucoup de choses dans
son e-mail parce qu’il est prof de culture
générale dans une prépa prestigieuse (en
plus d’être correcteur à HEC).
Il m’écrit notamment : « Votre
méthode est excellente et correspond
tout à fait à ce que je crois être
efficace pour la préparation des concours. »
J’ai même rencontré ce prof, et il m’a avoué
qu’il faisait désormais la même chose que moi : il
prépare des paragraphes modèles pour sa classe.
Voilà voilà, je t’ai déjà montré un témoignage
de plus que ce que j’avais promis — il y a encore
beaucoup d’autres sur la page de présentation.
Si tu veux en savoir plus sur mes paragraphes «
tout cuits », clique sur le lien qui apparaît
en haut à droite de la vidéo ; ou bien clique
sur celui qui est dans la description ; ou bien
encore tape directement https://1000idcg.com/50ptc
dans la barre de recherche.
Et puis si tu as des questions,
écris-moi à romain@1000idcg.com.
Bon courage pour le travail !